- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna talk about enzymes.
And in particular, we're
going to talk about the effect
of pH on enzymes, how acidic
or basic the environment is,
how that affects enzyme activity.
So just as a bit of a review,
enzymes are molecules that help
catalyze various reactions,
and they are all throughout
biological systems.
Most enzymes are proteins,
large proteins oftentimes,
made up of chains of amino acids.
And so I could draw a chain of amino acid,
where each of these circles
represents an amino acid.
And the primary structure
is just a sequence
of the amino acids, but there
is also a secondary structure
on how this amino acid
backbone interacts with itself.
And a lot of that is
based on hydrogen bonding.
So that amino acid and that amino acid,
maybe it forms some type of hydrogen bond.
And just as a review, a
hydrogen bond is an interaction
between hydrogen and a
more electronegative atom.
So for example, we've seen this in water.
Let me draw a couple of water
molecules right over here.
And this is all review.
In water, you have these covalent bonds
between the oxygen and the hydrogen.
So arguably, they're
sharing the electrons.
But because oxygen is
more electronegative,
it likes to hog the electrons more,
the electrons spend more
time around the oxygens.
So the oxygen end of a water molecule
gets a partially negative charge,
and then the hydrogen
ends of a water molecule
get a partially positive,
partially positive charge.
This is the Greek lowercase
delta for partially,
partial charge is what
it's typically used for.
And so the partially negative
ends would be attracted
to the partially positive
ends of another molecule,
and that's what hydrogen bonds are.
It's not always between
hydrogen and oxygen.
In fact, oftentimes it's
between hydrogen and nitrogen,
which is another electronegative atom.
And these hydrogen bonds,
not only do they help define
the secondary structure of the proteins,
which helps to find the
shape of the protein,
they can also interact with
the substrate of the protein,
the things that the protein's
trying to catalyze reactions on.
So for example, if that's the substrate,
and I'm just doing it as a big red circle,
parts of it might form hydrogen bonds
with the enzyme itself.
And if you want to see a
more complex picture of that,
this is a detailed schematic
of a substrate interacting with an enzyme,
where what you see in, circled in yellow,
that is the substrate here.
And you see these dotted lines,
those are the hydrogen bonds.
So you could see a hydrogen bond
between a hydrogen and a nitrogen,
a hydrogen bond between
an oxygen and a hydrogen.
And so the yellow part is a substrate.
And all the stuff that's
wrapping around it,
that is the enzyme itself.
So with that out of the way,
how does pH play into it?
Well, we just have to
remind ourselves what pH is.
pH, which is often viewed
as the power of hydrogen,
that's where the p comes from,
is the negative log, or at
least the way it's introduced
in many introductory chemistry class,
the negative log of the hydrogen
ion concentration.
And a hydrogen ion is
essentially a proton.
Well, how would this
affect an enzyme's shape
and its ability to interact
with the substrate,
the thing that it's trying to act on?
Well, if you have a bunch of,
depending on how many hydrogen ions
you have floating around,
and oftentimes it'll be
in the form of hydronium,
which is a water molecule
where the oxygen is bonded
to one extra hydrogen proton,
well, it might mess with
these hydrogen bonds,
where some of these hydrogen
protons usurp the bond
with the negative end of
one of these molecules
or repel some of the positive ends
of some of these molecules
in a certain way.
And so you could imagine
that different enzymes
might have a different level of activity
at different levels of pH,
and that actually is the case.
In fact, you'll often see a
diagram that looks like this.
So in the vertical axis,
you will often see reaction,
reaction
velocity,
where reaction velocity goes higher
as we go higher in the vertical direction.
And in this axis right over here,
you might see our level of pH.
And remember, pH, because you
have this negative out front,
a high hydrogen ion concentration,
because of this negative,
that will give you a low pH,
and that is associated with acidic,
acidic environments.
And a low hydrogen ion concentration,
that's associated with a high pH,
once again because of
this negative out front,
and that's associated with
a more basic situation.
And if your pH is around seven,
then that would be a neutral situation.
But different enzymes'
activities peak at different pHs.
So for example, you might
have an enzyme like this
whose activity peaks at a pH of,
let's say this is right
over here, a pH of four,
which is relatively acidic.
And you would typically
see this type of an enzyme
in, say, a place like the stomach,
which is a very acidic environment.
And then you might see other enzymes
that actually don't do too
well in an acidic environment,
but do quite well in a
more neutral environment.
So for example, this peak might
be at, say, a pH of seven.
And then you might have other enzymes
that do better in a basic environment.
And we actually do see
this in the human body.
For example, lipase,
which is an enzyme that breaks down fat,
when it's found in the stomach,
that particular version of lipase,
it actually has optimum
activity closer to this,
at a pH of roughly four or five.
While lipase that is
secreted from the pancreas,
which acts in the small intestines,
which is a more neutral
environment or even slightly basic,
its optimal activity is at a pH of eight.
So I will leave you there.
Big picture is, is that a
lot of an enzyme's shape
or its ability to
interact with a substrate
is based on hydrogen bonds.
And so you can imagine hydrogen
bonds could be influenced
by hydrogen ion concentration.
And so because of that,
depending on your enzyme
and sometimes the substrate
that you're dealing with,
you might have different
reaction velocities
at different pHs,
with some enzymes doing
better in acidic environments
and other enzymes doing better
in neutral or basic environments.